so howwwas yoor here well you were that
was so excited yay I was really excited
was a good holiday how was your New
Year's it was so good you know why why I
don't remember uh I kind of just chilled
out but I did get stuck in some traffic
a little crazy but I had snacks in the
back so I was pretty content with that
okay Dave how about you I was in Miami
which sounds exciting but I actually was
in bed at literally 9:30 my New Year's
with Anderson Cooper Andy Cohen and Ryan
Seacrest and had a great time nice yeah
you mean watching on the TV they weren't
all in Miami and I will ruin it welcome
to movie threesome I'm Tiffany Smith and
I'm Kristian harloff and joining us
today it is offend anglish chief
correspondent Dave Karger is here hey
guys obviously you're huge fan of award
shows but how long have you been
covering them I've been watching them
since I was a kid I mean I was always
obsessed and then when I used to work at
Entertainment Weekly I started going to
the awards and the very first Oscars I
ever went to was in 1998 when Titanic
111 Oscars so it was all downhill from
there afternoon therefore that that time
how can it ever get better
you've been doing this for a while but
do you have any particular favorite
award show moment hands down the best
coolest thing I ever got to do was a
couple years ago I was the backstage
correspondent for Oscar calm which meant
that I was the second person to
interview after Kelly Ripa to interview
Octavia Spencer right after she won the
Oscar for the health and she started
crying while I was interviewing her what
is the energy like Oh in a moment like
that insane because this is someone
reaching the absolute pinnacle of their
career and to just be standing right
next to them there's so much emotion and
fragility that it's really exciting well
I know exactly what that's like
because that's what happens to me every
time I win a box office bet I don't want
any though very much I Tiffany how can
you answer that question it's 2016 which
means we're starting a new slate 0-0
neither of us have won yet well we have
the award specialist here revenants
gonna be mentioned a lot I think during
award season so why not bet on that one
shirt do it alright
okay so revenant since we are starting
from scratch - we don't know who goes
first so Dave we need your help okay I
will flip this coin you call it heads
Oh tail because I am a great person I am
going to say that you should go first
for the revenant I think it's gonna make
14 interesting um I'm not going too far
away from that but I will say 16 million
what do you think of our bets I think
you're gonna win yeah I mean it's
between 14 cuz it's something look at
what he played made and it was sorry
guys was hateful eight 16 or 18 I was
shy shot when she asked I was like I
have a sure revenant we'll still kind of
be going up against Star Wars but
obviously it's got Leo and Tom Hardy I
think there's gonna be some more
shedding and the fact that Star Wars is
now are shedding yeah [ __ ] on the
numbers Oh what like I don't know what
you're talking about shedding if that's
a movie tournament I don't know I
finished my thoughts Dave didn't know
what you know anything about people
bringing their dogs yeah you know I'm
gonna shave the dog that's a big thing
now I'm sorry they didn't know what
you're talking what are you and I mean
nobody kept going with it that's the
point of this well now that we have our
first weekly wager on the books we need
you guys to keep sending in those loser
shoulds use the hashtag on YouTube in
the comments below on Twitter on
Facebook and then Christian will have to
do them cuz he's gonna lose a lot this
year you've seen Star Wars right don't
get cocky kid you guys are such dorks
and I love it it's fun okay I'll take
that title I will take that title but a
title that you've taken is Oscar
obsessive I do call myself an Oscar
obsessive okay so we want to challenge
that okay in a little segment that we
call Oscars
Oh No are you ready yes but also scared
all right
so Christian also you're gonna give him
the first question who is the youngest
Oscar winner kind of a trick question
Shirley Temple but that was a special
award if you're gonna say Oscar winner
it's gonna be Tatum O'Neal for Paper
Moon she's ten Wow I was gonna say I was
gonna say can you say her a bonus point
I was gonna say how old it he said
without a ten absolutely correct who are
the oldest actors to have won Oscars
Jessica Tandy
that's correct there's an is another
there is another is it a like that so
she's the oldest woman who's the oldest
man hmm was in 2011 Christopher Plummer
yeah that is crazy
where was the first Oscars ceremony held
in 1929 at the Roosevelt Hotel
that was easy that one's easy that was
really very really impressive thank you
so much can I actually have a little bit
of that that's not that impressive
okay so since we have you on the show
let's talk about who you think is gonna
win in some of the big Oscar categories
okay what do you wanna start with how
about Best Actress there's three women
that are kind of at the top of the IPE
Blanchett for Carole brie Larson for
room and Saoirse Ronan for Brooklyn and
if I had to pick a winner right now I
think brie Larson is gonna win how does
it break down for you where it's like
Blanchett vs. Rooney Mara yes they've
been campaigning for Rooney in the
supporting category and I feel like it's
better for a film to if they got lead
actress Supporting Actress
if Rooney Mara gets put in supporting I
think she'll win what do you think for
lead actor that's a tough one because
there's like seven guys who are fighting
for the five spot I think you can
definitely say Leo DiCaprio gets
nominated for the revenant gotta be here
keeps getting nominated keeps losing to
people that I think have been better by
that much and I might happen again this
year Eddie Redmayne will be in there I
think Michael Fassbender will be in
there then the other two spots could be
Matt Damon could be Will Smith could be
Bryan Cranston for Trumbo but I think
Leo's gonna win guys but I also really
really liked the big short
and so I'm like I know people are
talking a little bit about Steve Carell
in that role and for me watching him in
that I'm like this guy is an actor how
about Best Director well I think you
guys are gonna love this category Ridley
Scott gets nominated for the Martian
George Miller for Mad Max and then I
think you have Alejandro and you are a 2
for the revenant Tom McCarthy for
spotlight and the big kind of Dark Horse
who's coming on strong guys is JJ Abrams
I think Star Wars is becoming more and
more of an awards movie as we're seeing
some of the Guild Awards nominations
come out it's a player I want George
Miller to win yeah not just shot as I
want George Miller ah if I had to pick a
winner right now I think it's Ridley
Scott he's never won he's directed a
Best Picture winner gladiator he's been
nominated several times and he's never
won so I think this might be his year I
think the same thing could be said for
George Miller that he's never won before
and this is such an original film and
it's all from him like that that is what
I think is a little bit different all
right let's finish it off with what you
think might get nominated for Best
Picture there's a lot of big blockbuster
movies that are gonna be in the race
like Mad Max the Martian and possibly
even Star Wars there's a lot of female
centric movies like Brooklyn and room
and Carroll that are all gonna be in
there and then I think other movies that
are gonna fill it out are the big short
yeah and spotlight but it's a great
group of movies this year a great list
what do you think is gonna win
I think the Martian is in the lead right
oh really I do
all right well since we can't predict
exactly who's gonna make it into the
Oscars why don't we just on the show
because then it will get us to the
Oscars even faster right yeah will goes
faster to me winning box office week
good
the weekly wages box office week yeah
pretty busy award season and I am super
excited about it
we should also tell people that the
actual Oscar nominations are on January
14th so we'll see if all of our
predictions come true and I'm gonna be
on The Today Show that morning with Matt
Savannah so you can check that out too
we'd also like to thank Jesse Hernandez
for that amazing fan art of the
hatefully love that thing it is so cool
and hateful eight in Quentin Tarantino
are something we didn't really talk
about with an award season do you think
they'll be any nominations for it I
don't think it gets nominated for Best
Picture or director but screenplay has a
great shot and Jennifer Jason Leigh for
Supporting Actress she was so great
although I love that movie I don't think
it's gonna get in the major major
categories alright so thank you guys so
much for watching make sure that you
subscribe right over there and then
check out more episodes right there and
make sure that you check out the
Fandango movie clips app on your
smartphone and check out us each and
every week here on movie three so shut
it
we didn't shed that [ __ ]